let's bring in Richard Roeper the
Chicago movie critic Richard Roeper calm
Richard good morning thanks for joining
us on short notice where would you stand
with the which movie is the number one
seed well good morning Dan you know it's
like the Academy Awards there's no cut
and dried rule for what the supporting
performance what's cameo now you guys
are foot pulp fiction in a cameo
category hear that no no no no and no no
this is a movie that you would want to
be have a cameo in so all that movie I
want to add a cameo in be uh I gotta go
with you I got its pulp fiction's no
there's no doubt about it I mean out of
all of the Samuel objects moving it's
all fiction I mean that movie has the
best repeatability factor of any movie
probably sent the Godfather meaning that
if you see it you want to see it again
and if you're clicking around the dial
and it's on no matter what point movie
you're at you're gonna watch the rest of
the film it's called fiction and the
story that's where I went but Paulie do
you want to state your case to Richard
I'm just shocked because Richards is old
school and respects the craft of
moviemaking info wait what would you
talk about Quentin Tarantino making a
movie I'm just saying Martin Scorsese's
Goodfellas is considered one of the
greatest films of all time I think and I
think it's more rewatchable than pulp
fiction it's right up there look we're
talking about Goodfellas probably top 10
PI football fiction the top 25 uh but
when you talk about you know having a
memorable cameo are having a memorable
memorable appearance I think when people
think about fellas they think of 20
performances probably before they think
of samuel l jackson cameo so for me
personally like you know pulp fiction is
more memorable pulp fiction's when i
would personally rather be in we were
also looking at the number of movies
Samuel Jackson's in the Guinness Book of
World Records for his movies have
grossed more money at the box office
than any other actor well that's crazy
yeah well it's pretty amazing result
areas like you know you can say anything
you want about the three Star Wars
movies that you know aren't as beloved
as the rest of them but those movies
made
of dollars and he's also a guy who
worked for a long long time before you
really kind of hit it you know in movies
like jungle fever early 90 stuff like
we're talking about like pulp fiction so
you know this guy who's on Spenser for
hire back in the day in a supporting
role so I think you know Sam Jackson
really appreciates when you can become a
in demand popular terrific actor that
you work and let's face it Batman works
you do not have to go you're looking to
any cineplex just walk in each of the
twenty-four theaters odds are okay on
screen or one of them at any given
moment or Morgan Freeman or Morgan
favorite culturally bigger impact do the
right thing jungle fever pulp fiction
good thing there's all those movies very
important but do the right thing it was
so far ahead of its time because you
could you could put that same movie in
big screens right now is current
releases I mean it speaks to so many
things are still happening in this
country and as good as the other films
are do the right thing is one of the
handful of movies at trends and cinema
and has people to this day they know
that phrase they know what it's about
and nobody knows you don't know anything
about the state of race in America 25
years ago are now watch do the right
thing best upcoming movies this summer
well I'm really looking forward to
suicide squad which comes out in August
and if your folks don't know dan this is
that basically the Dirty Dozen with
superheroes you know you get a bunch of
the work worse nastiest horrible
villains of all time you tell them I
we're gonna let you out of prison but
you gotta do something approaching good
are you gonna get killed if are or you
might die on the spot so it's
essentially it's a comic book Dirty
Dozen um I Deadpool the the sequel when
does that that start like that there has
to be a sequel is as great as that movie
was right oh yeah they got yeah it's not
a franchise as you know I think it
Reynolds was great as Deadpool the one
thing that I thought kind of took away
from that movie is a sense they spent so
much time in his origin story town is
how I became
deadpool and you know we get that far
too often every time we get spider-man
we get another Punk in a high school lab
by a spider we know how he became
spider-man let's pick it up the story
right where we deal already spider-man
that that's why I think the sequel to
Deadpool be better than the original
because we know who he is how he got
there what it's all about what about the
infiltrator with bryan cranston you
can't go wrong with bryan cranston right
bryan cranston's one of those guys again
we talked about you know Malcolm the
middle and some other stuff but what you
got that breaking bread breaking bad
that you know that break alcohol and
knocked it out of the park you know
there are a lot of actors you'd be like
well what's he gonna do after that he's
always going to be Walter White boom he
gets nominated for Trumbo bang he does
LBJ on stage and broadway wins the Tony
and if you haven't checked out the HBO
movie replays LBJ you gotta check it out
five-second Center you forget that it's
bryan cranston so i was afford to
anything he's going to do but if she
become the best actor he's right he's in
the conversation as we say now yeah but
we always in the conversation the
conversation about being in the
conversational Nestle people look in the
next day but if we used to sell one of
the best nights it he's in the
conversation for the Heisman Trophy he's
in the conversation for MVP so I would
say that about Bryan Cranston is in the
conversation okay but who else is in the
conversation well it's something that
what the one of its one of the same
people are so I you know but Meryl
Streep isn't isn't retiring and just
painting on a branch in Virginia at this
point and you know Sean Penn and and
robert downey jr's probably our best
actor who hasn't won an Oscar I i I'd
make that argument right now you know
the fact that he hasn't is kind of
amazing as you know who's better than
that was better than ever done in
January as well that will they ever give
an Academy Award to a superhero no not
not not not in our lifetime I don't
think there's certain you know a lot of
the old-school Hollywood try to just
silliness the comedies don't get
rewarded animated films are put in the
separate animated category because
people don't respect you know the
special effects much a CGI and all that
and same thing with a superhero movies
and they're really not written for
actors to win awards when you think
about i think the downey could have won
for the first ironman because them he
was he was playing Khatami stark is
probably to me the most interesting
altar
call of all the superheroes you think
about a car campus stiff Bruce Wayne's
kind of a bore Tony Stark it's bath day
you do a whole movie about him he could
never put on the Iron Man costume maybe
a fascinating character before I let you
go when I die at the Academy Awards will
they put me up my picture in memoriam
with the other actors who died that year
yes because you got a canon of work
thank you you look now but but the
bigger question is will you will you
follow someone who gets the loud roar of
applause cinematographers honored five
who gets the smattering of I won't care
Richard I you know my family and legion
of fans they will be the one that care
about that one second of air time at the
Academy Awards you and like the the
seventh Baldwin brother that year back
to that gimme gimme bald thank you
Richard he is Richard Roeper calm the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience